Um zu überprüfen, wie sicher Medikamente
oder Chemikalien sind, werden bislang Tiersuche
durchgeführt - und das verpflichtend.
In Deutschland sind es alleine etwa 400.000
Tiere pro Jahr: Kaninchen, Ratten, Mäuse,
aber auch Hunde und Katzen, denen beispielsweise
Chemikalien in die Augen geträufelt wird,
um zu kontrollieren, ob sie ätzend sind.
Ein Forschungsteam aus den USA hat jetzt eine
Software entwickelt, die die Gefährlichkeit
von chemischen Stoffen mindestens genauso
gut einschätzen kann wie Tierversuche - zum
Teil sogar noch besser!
Das Ende der Tierversuche?- Clixoom Science
& Fiction, Hier gibt es täglich faszinierende
Wissenschaftsvideos.
Abonniert den Kanal, nur dann verpasst ihr
nichts. herzlich willkommen!
Wir haben hier bei Clixoom Science & Fiction
schon öfter darüber berichtet, dass Künstliche
Intelligenz Lage ist, die Forschung in verschiedenen
Bereichen zu revolutionieren.
Und die Revolution geht weiter.
Krankheiten könnten schon bald durch Algorithmen
diagnostiziert werden, Genome kostengünstig
sequenziert werden und neue Medikamente entwickelt
werden.
Computer könnten für jeden einzelnen Patienten
individuell angepasste Medikamenten-Cocktails
finden.
Statt einen Wirkstoff nach dem anderen zu
testen, könnte intelligente Software auf
Grundlage der genomischen Daten des Patienten
die Literatur nach der perfekten Medikamenten-Kombination
durchsuchen.
Auf einen Schlag können so tausende von Kombinationen
analysiert werden und dem Ärzteteam vorgeschlagen
werden.
Genau daran tüfteln große Tech-Firmen wie
Facebook, Amazon, Apple, Google und Microsoft.
Und genau auf dieser Grundlage hat jetzt ein
Forschungsteam aus den USA eine Computersimulation
erstellt, die in der Lage ist, Chemikalien
nach ihrer Giftigkeit sehr genau vorausberechnen.
Notwendig dafür waren jede Menge maschinelle
Lerneinheiten mit zahlreichen Versuchs- und
Sicherheitsdaten.
Um Stoffe zu analysieren, benutzt das Computerprogramm
viele verschiedene Daten: Beispielsweise Ergebnisse
aus bereits durchgeführten Laborexperimenten
oder Tierversuchen, Daten zu der Molekülstruktur
der Stoffe und sonstiges Wissen zu der möglichen
Wirkung im menschlichen Körper.
Das Computerprogramm ist zudem in der Lage,
die zu untersuchenden Chemikalien mit ähnlichen
Strukturen zu vergleichen, bei denen die Wirkung
bereits erforscht ist.
Als Grundlage für seine Berechnungen standen
der Software dann eine gigantische Datenmenge
zur Verfügung.
Konkret nämlich die Daten zu 10.000 chemischen
Stoffen und 800.000 Tierversuchen - allesamt
von der Europäischen Chemikalienagentur (ECHA).
Diese konnte die Software dann nutzen, um
die Wahrscheinlichkeit einer möglichen giftigen
Wirkung von bislang noch unbekannten Substanzen
vorauszusagen.
Und das Ergebnis ist beeindruckend, denn die
Ergebnisse der Algorithmen sind eindeutig.
Eine gesundheitsschädigende Wirkung konnte
die Software zu 85-95 Prozent richtig einschätzen.
Tierversuche sind dagegen oft lange nicht
so eindeutig.
Bei mehreren Testläufen kommen durchaus auch
unterschiedliche Ergebnisse zustande.
Die Wahrscheinlichkeit nämlich, dass das
Ergebnis eines Tierversuches im zweiten Anlauf
dem ersten Durchgang entspricht, liegt nämlich
nur bei 78-96 Prozent.
Die Europäische Chemikalienagentur (ECHA)
jedenfalls ist solchen computerbasierten Methoden
zur Sicherheitsprüfung aufgeschlossen.
Schon jetzt fordert sie Unternehmen auf, diese
einzusetzen.
Doch die Leitlinien dazu müssen in der Praxis
auch umgesetzt werden.
Und auch die US-Umweltschutzbehörde ist schon
seit längerer Zeit auf der Suche nach Alternativen
und hat eine Strategie entwickelt, mit der
Verfahren gefördert werden, die ohne Tierversuche
auskommen.
Diese Entwicklungen könnten in Zukunft tatsächlich
das Leid von Millionen Tieren verhindern.
Wie fühlt es sich an Tiere zu töten?
Sehr wie soll ich sagen interessantes Video
von mailab.
Draufklicken, anschauen und mailab natürlich
abonnieren.
Bis dann, bleibt dran.